bonjour tout le monde ah je suis très
content d'être là avec nous alors je
suis pas orateurs comme les autres donc
et vue je vais essayer de parler un peu
enfoncé donc j'ai eu droit les notes on
est là pour essayer de faire en sorte
pas trop faire de faute
donc oui moi c'est terreur médecine je
viens de modesto californie et je
l'occasion de revenir ici puisque
dès demain je prends l'avion pour aller
en roumanie
donc vu que c'était le premier thé l'x
ici j'avais envie d'avoir l'occasion de
pouvoir voir ce qui a été fait et
c'était super cool je pense qu'on peut
encore vous dire allez les orateurs ont
passé c'était c'était vraiment très bien
même si bon j'ai pas trop compris
c'était très bien alors forcément aussi
le côté de ces rixes on essaye de voix
pour améliorer donc j'ai l'occasion de
venir ici pour voir aussi des
changements qui pourraient être faits
etc
et puis vu qu' on n'a plus le droit de
faire d'espionnage avec la msa donc je
viens directement ici c'est tout c'est
plus simple pour prendre les notes
donc je suis très très content d'être
ici dans cette ville qui très joli même
sujet parle plus beaucoup beaucoup de
choses encore mais c'est très joli et
malgré les différends a d'ailleurs
événement historique il ya eu deux
dernières fois qu'on est passé nous les
américains s'étaient pas forcément le
très bon souvenir mais elle l'a en tout
cas c'est très chouette est en tout cas
je j'ai des amis qui sont déjà venus ici
qui m'ont dit qu'on se sent plus un le
plus en bretagne ici que dans les autres
villes
donc c'est vrai j'ai hâte de découvrir
un peu tout ce qu'il ya aux alentours
le cathédrale de saint louis le château
est tous assez brest
désolé j'ai pas pris sa fiche
du coup je suis très content d'être ici
aussi un malgré la seconde guerre et on
m'a dit qu'ici on se sent plus en
bretagne à lorient que dans les autres
villes et j'ai hâte de découvrir
je suis bongo coin b j'ai hâte de voir
en tout cas
donc tout ce que j'ai pu voir au niveau
organisation et aussi les orateurs il ya
plein de choses qui sont très très très
très intéressant je voudrais aussi qu'on
a produit l'association attrape rêves
qui a organisé tout ça donc s'il vous
plaît un produit 100
j'ai j'ai eu un peu peur au début
puisque je me suis dit allez voir la
clim alors ça va s'appeler plutôt
attrape la grève mais en fait j'ai
repris la clim d'occident l'organisation
j'ai beaucoup aimé par exemple à la
porte
à l'entrée la le côté à tout un charme
de attrape rêves thierry qui a là bas
c'est le côté vraiment qui donne envie
donc tu es et on m'a dit qu'il
connaissait my way donc j'ai hâte
d'entendre
et puis bon après un si haut dans
l'organisation pendant l'entrée des
spectateurs
si vous n'avez qu'une chanson for me le
dire j'ai d'autres chansons parce que
c'est là était la même en boucle pendant
30 minutes
donc là je prends un petit beyoncé et si
aussi assis pendant la pause les
pâtisseries
c'est beaucoup c'est pas ça nous
forcément c'est un peu plus je sais pas
si c'est nathalie c'est toi qui a fait
les poches
c'était peut-être pas si bon que ça en
fait un bond cette idée pas mr vcd fin
alors pour ce qui est de 22 les
différents orateurs qui sont passés tout
d'abord il ya eu un dominique
merci et beaucoup c'était c'était très
chouette le parler de tous les bienfaits
des bénévoles
les bénévoles qu'on peut appeler amis
c'est vrai que quand je regarde mon
profil facebook
je vois que je fais beaucoup de
bénévolat puisque bon on n'a pas
forcément des amis qui sont tous ainsi
je ferai aussi de la pub pour vous je
sais pas encore comment tu es en jetant
des chaussures c'est à voir
ensuite il ya eu une nathalie nathalie
que la merci à eux j'aime beaucoup le
concept de fait de faire la cuisine pour
améliorer la condition humaine avec des
patates jeunes où on est on est d'accord
avec vous faut dire que nous aux
etats-unis depuis le mariage gay on n'a
jamais autant voyez la paix c'est le
black française que m'a dit thierry de
gipat y compris au coeur en tout cas on
va essayer de préparer un gratin pour le
corps et du non on verra ah si il ya eu
jean paul nadine aussi bienvenus
jean-paul nadine qui pardon qui nous a
faits parlent de moyens qu'il a trouvée
pour essayer de gagner à toute la
compétition maintenant le vin non mais
c'est ainsi karim tu avais comme témoin
trente minutes donc et 30 semaines de
plus
serge aignan n'empêcherait et veut faire
croire qu'il était footballeur et les
gaines des compétitions mais il sait pas
pourquoi
ensuite après on a eu à nadine qui bat
qui aide beaucoup la création d'art
éphémère et c'est vraiment super
chouette
en espérant que vos idées l aile dure
elle perdure et que ça continue encore
et quand tu ne te courir
attention porte un forcément la dina
quand même réinventer le groupe de
dourges 6 en bretagne ne s'est par
ailleurs ramona d asi pour
l'organisation un poids ça me fatigue
est passé vous vous êtes trompés dans le
sens six instruments il était comme ça
c'était du coup sa voisine où ils ont
été donnés par les voies les ports il
était embêté que les deux cas n'est pas
forcément l'idéal
voilà c'était pour fait qui trichait pas
pour montrer son avec le violon 1
c'est difficile de tricher j'ai vu que
vous savez chanter aujourd'hui c'est le
fait national de l'uni est ce que vous
pouvez chanter l'hymne américain pour
moi d'accord
non mais on m'avait dit qu'on enfonce on
a dix ans de retard mais vous allez là
le connaître bientôt n'en sais ça fait
30 ans que ça existe
je sais j'ai été créée au tout premier
texte ensuite on a eu 1 1 q strophes
grange
j'ai rien à dire c'est parfait
je tiens retourner chez moi un tact tu
as beau avoir dit que che mais la
domination je dirai rien c'était très
bien
et demain pour un mari à tous car je
reprends l'avion donc je vais voir sir
forcément sentir 103 gino jinro
bah je sais pas si je la fais demain
pour l'instant c'est que 30% de mon idée
en tout cas pour conclure le côté ted
c'est très important ce tour à la fin
puisque c'est le moment où c'est le and
if a mené tout le et 6 ainsi qu'on se
pose comme question pendant qu'on
regarde et si je n'étais pas venu voir
la conférence
et si en regardant 6,1 à tallinn est
parfait le cuisine et si jean paul puis
on paul avait fait du foot est ce qu'il
aurait gardé le même coupe de cheveux
est-ce que et si christophe était pas
tortueux mais plutôt belette
c'est pas du coup 1 et après arrive le
hana et maintenant et maintenant ils
savent ce qu'ils font ils ont tout plein
de projets qui sont pour se montrer bien
mais vous et non
emma trop qu'est ce que je fais est ce
que après avoir vu ça je reste à voir en
faire est-ce que moi maintenant je me
lance faire quelque chose
est ce que maintenant que je me rends
compte que je me suis laissé embarquer
par un mec qui fait semblant d'avoir
l'accent californien
est-ce que je vais être plus curieux des
gens avec je croise en tout cas ted
c'est forcément quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
je reprends le slogan d'un d'une marque
de magasins qui vont décéder ces
agitateurs de curiosité vous n'hésitez
pas à continuer de tout y est merci
beaucoup bonne soirée